what is the meaning of life
our existence here on earth
the whole thing
[Laughter]
no no you can't you can't i will not
allow you to uh to try to escape
answering this question
you have to answer definitively
uh because they're they're surely
surely don knuth there must be an answer
what is the answer is it 42 or where are
you yeah well i don't think it's the
numerical that's that's good
that was that was in in zen and okay but
all right so so anyway um
it's only for me and
but i
but i personally
think of
my belief that
that god exists although i have no idea
what that means
but i believe that there is
some
something
beyond human
uh
capabilities
and it might be uh
it might be some ai
but but whatever it is but but whatever
i but i do believe that
that there is uh
something that goes beyond
the realm of human understanding
but but that that i can
try to
learn more about
how to resonate with whatever that
being would like me to do
so do you think you can
have occasional glimpses of that being i
i strive for that
not that i
ever think i'm going to get close to it
but but it's not
it's not for me it's it's saying what
should i do
that that big being wants me to do
that's that's you know
i'm trying to ask
what what that
i mean does that being want me to to be
talking to lex friedman right now you
know and i said yes okay but thank you
well thank you
what i'm trying to say is
i'm not trying to say what
of all the
strategies i could choose or something
which one
i i i try to do it not not strategically
but i try to
to
imagine that i'm following somebody's
wishes even though
you're not smart enough to to know what
they are yeah
but it's that funny little dance well i
i i mean this ai or whatever is it
probably is
is smart enough to help to give me clues
and uh to make the whole journey from
include a clue
yeah a fun one yeah i mean it's as so
many people have said it's the journey
not the destination
and
people live
live through crises help each other all
these
things come up
history repeats itself
you try to say
in the world today
is there any government that's working i
i read history i i know that things were
they they they were they were
they were a lot worse
in many ways there's a lot of bad things
all the time
and i read about
you know i look at
things and people had good ideas and
they were working on great projects and
then i know that it didn't succeed
though in the end
uh but but the new insight i've gotten
actually
in that way was i was reading
uh what what book was i reading now
recently it was
it was by ken follett and it was called
the man from saint petersburg but it but
but it was talking about the prequel to
world war one
and winston churchill
according to this book uh sees that
that germany has been spending all its
gold reserves uh building up a huge
military
and there's no question that if germany
would attack england that england would
be wiped out
so he wants russia to help
to attack germany from the other side
because germany doesn't have enough of
an army to
be fighting two wars at one
okay now
then there's an anarchist in russia
who sees
that
wars are
something that leaders start but
actually people get killed
and so he wants
to stop
any alliance between england and russia
because that would mean that
down the people of russia would would be
killed that wouldn't be otherwise killed
all right and so his his life's goal
is to assassinate
a russian prince who's visiting england
because that will make will mean the
czar will not form the alliance all
right
so we have this
question
about what should the government do
should it actually do something that
will lead to
you know is is the war inevitable or is
there a way to have peace and and this
just did and it struck me that if i were
in a position of responsibility work for
people's lives
in most cases i wouldn't have i wouldn't
have any confidence that any of my
decisions were good
that that these these questions are too
hard
probably for any human being but
certainly for me
well i think
i think coupling the
not being sure
that the decisions are right so that
that's actually a
really good thing
coupled with the fact that you do have
to make a decision
and carry the burden of that and
ultimately i have faith in human beings
and the great leaders to arise
and help build a better world i mean
that's the hope of democracy that's done
yeah then let's hope that we can uh and
enhance their abilities with uh
with algorithms
[Laughter]
uh well put done
it's such a huge honor i've you've been
an inspiration to me and to millions for
such a long time um thank you
for spending your really valuable time
with me once again it's a huge honor i
really enjoyed this conversation
you